un grand soir et ils sont quatre à les
castors guerre montréal marie vastel à
tahoua emmanuelle latraverse à ottawa
michel ces ogm montréal messieurs dames
bonsoir soir avant d'aller dans le vif
du sujet on a vu la sortie de certains
ministres à leur écoute on c'est
quelques secondes mélanie joly qui a
aussi parlé au micro on écoute et on
revient mais ça me fait plaisir
premièrement d'être la nouvelle ministre
du patrimoine
c'est vraiment un plaisir pour moi
d'avoir l'honneur justement de pouvoir
créer des ponts avec la communauté à le
milieu des arts partout à travers le
canada
emilie new era in times of swing voilà
c'était pas très long mais c'était pour
pour montrer au sipi manuel on a parlé
ce matin lors de cette émission spéciale
ce genre d'opération là les ministres
qui viennent parler après un conseil des
ministres faisaient presque dix ans
qu'on n'avait pas vu ça à ottawa donc
promesses engagements d'ouverture
monsieur trudeau le répéter aujourd'hui
je le disais au tout début d'émission
puis je vous laisse aller là dessus
après moi ya deux choses qui nous ont
frappés à une manuelle on est ensemble
ce matin madame moncef réfugiée afghane
responsable 30 ans responsable de la
réforme démocratique 1 et une femme
autochtone marianne joe johnson ministre
de la justice
deux très forts symboles aujourd'hui
avec tout le reste mes alec qu'est-ce
que vous qu'est ce qui vous a frappé
vous ce matin écoute madame manser fonds
aux institutions démocratiques j'ai eu
le même réflexe que vos patrice kouté
une réfugiée afghane quand on sait les
problèmes de gouvernance qui lie en
afghanistan et elle va être responsables
des institutions démocratiques c'est
quand même un signal assez important
assez intéressant c'est elle qui va
devoir normalement réformer le mode de
scrutin est donc une domination quand
même assez importante
on entendait mélanie joly tout à l'heure
qui est probablement avec stéphane dion
ministre du québec la plus importante
qu'on regarde la composition des comités
ministériels du cabinet comment ils sont
faits madame joly qui siège à quatre
comités notamment celui du programme
gouvernemental et des résultats qui le
comité le plus important du cabinet
présidé par justin trudeau qui
s'occupent à angers en gros lot de la
planification stratégique du
gouvernement
elle est la seule avec jean yves duclos
assiégeaient ce comité là donc oui elle
est ministre du patrimoine là mais avec
les charges qu'elle est dans les
différents comités clairement la mélanie
joly c'est aussi d'un ministre important
aux yeux de justin trudeau
on va revenir sur le poids d'un relatif
du québec entre autres et tout ça mais
d'abord premier tour de table je veux
continuer marie vastel des surprises
pour vous y en a eu plusieurs mais
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé le plus ce
matin j'ai ce qui m'a frappé c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de novices dans des postes
très importants aux novices de leur
carrière professionnelle antérieure mais
novice de la politique quand même le
ministre des finances bill morneau qui
aucune expérience fédérale
ça m'a surpris moi personnellement je
voyais scop bryson atterrir là il a
atterri au conseil du trésor commerce
international alors qu'il faut gérer le
partenariat transpacifique christian
poulin qui était député mais qui est pas
d'expérience de ministre à
l'environnement alors j'ai par contre
l'économie qui connaît le sujet mais
gérer un ministère c'est quand même
autre chose
catherine mais canal environnements qui
peuvent non plus d'expérience de
ministre et qu'il va devoir le gérer la
conférence de paris sous peu donc des
grosses responsabilités à des gens
nouveaux venus et stéphane dion vous
affaires étrangères moi ça m'a surpris
et dominic leblanc qui est un qui est
très proche de justin trudeau qui ne
s'est pas lancée à la chefferie pour lui
laisser la place on s'entend qu'il
aurait probablement gagné de toute façon
mais dont il avait fait ce pacte de
de non agression et qui est leader en
chambre je pense qu'on le voit beaucoup
mais je pense qu'il aurait peut-être
espérer plus grand portefeuille quand
même mais celle ci moi ce que maryse
immosky mais ce que je constate c'est un
énorme effort de changement de
génération c'est plus le cabinet de jean
dans la soixantaine c'est un cabinet
qu'il saute par dessus une génération
cela dit saviez avec un coût et un
risque
il ya des gens qui vont devoir faire
deux apprentissages très difficile en
même temps le premier c'est faire de la
politique être en chambre répondent aux
questions est responsable de tout
chauvinisme terre de vins devant tout le
monde et l'autre si jerry et ministère
puis et ministère même si on devine
d'expérience de gestion dans le secteur
privé le ministère c'est une bibitte
complètement différente ça ne marche pas
de la même façon et il ya toutes sortes
d'exemples de gens qui ont eu de la
misère à prendre ça alors quand on est
en réussite et monsieur mono sur
bordeaux tu es un homme d'affaires qui
avait eu beaucoup de succès en même
temps il faut apprendre à être un
politicien répondants chambre puis en
même temps il faut apprendre à gérer le
ministère des finances va toujours vous
avez essayé de vous en passer une petite
vite le 18 il y en a 18 heures et deux
tiers du québec je tiens ce qui est
manuel
je pense que quand on parle du risque
que comporte tout ce sang neuf
ce vent de fraîcheur au sein du
gouvernement c'est ce qui explique aussi
le choix de dominique leblanc comme
leader parlementaire avec tant de
ministres qui ont des grosses
responsabilités des gourous des grosses
responsabilités législatives aussi à
mettre de l'avant
on sent que monsieur trudeau a voulu à
ce chapitre
comptez ce vieux routier si vous me
passez l'expression quelqu'un qui
maîtrise la joute parlementaire sur le
bout des doigts
justement pour naviguer une partie du
moins des écueils qui attend cette
nouvelle équipe parce que il faut faire
avancer les priorités du gouvernement au
sein de la machine gouvernementale
d'où ma collègue le mentionnait ce
nouveau comité du cabinet pour la mise
en oeuvre des priorités
il faut aussi les faire cheminer à
travers l'appareil législatif est là et
donc c'est peut-être justement ce qui
explique le choix de monsieur de
monsieur
de monsieur leblanc c'est le pari de
ceux de ce gouvernement là un jeune
premier ministe 43 ans est donc libéré
au bout de cette idée là en osant
prendre les risques qui vont avec sa
candidature et les risques qui vont avec
la promesse qui le fait aux canadiens
oui tout à fait et alec on parle on a
parlé de parité évidemment la voici 15
on fait comme si tu es bon mais ça y est
c'est quand même c'est un
accomplissement important aujourd'hui
parité hommes et femmes et diversité là
je pense faut être aveugle pour ne pas
voir aujourd'hui que le cabinet de
justin trudeau ressemble davantage aux
canadiens qui c'était le cas auparavant
alec way absolument faut lui donner une
bonne note là dessus et j'ai bien aimé
sa réponse aussi quand on lui a demandé
pourquoi vous avez un cabinet à parité
homme-femme usb parce qu'on est en 2015
voilà donc c'est assez simple ça dès
qu'on en parle depuis un bon moment mais
peut-être qu'effectivement on était
rendu leur ont été rendus le duo du côté
du canada d'avoir commis un cabinet de
parité hommes femmes
je peux mettre trop de bémol là dessus
je pense que c'est un accomplissement
qui est intéressant je souligne quand
même que tous les gros ministères
économiques sont entre les mains des
hommes
donc on pense aux finances au conseil du
trésor au transport des gros ministères
comme la défense ils se moquent les
affaires autochtones ou les ici c'est
pas important lors qu'ils sont dirigés
par des femmes mais on encore un
concentration économique dans les mines
dans les mains des hommes et on encore
sur 10 comité du cabinet on en a 8 où il
ya plus d'hommes que de femmes sur les
10 ou et ont gagné en position non on
regarde la composition se dit que le
pouvoir et est une chose la composition
du cabinet une chose de pouvoir en est
une autre aussi donc je pense que c'est
un bon accomplissement l usage voir de
plus en plus de femmes qui vont être
très importantes au cabinet et c'est une
bonne chose mais on a encore un petit
peu de chemin à faire je pense la marie
je suis d'accord mais par contre neutre
et quand même que justice ça va être un
gros ministère parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses à défaire le si on veut ou à
refaire ça n'est pas le point de vue
environnement ça va être un cours au
ministère parce que c'est une des
priorités des libéraux et commerce
international ou s'il faut pas l'oublier
on suit trois grosses stars dont pour
rien quand même trois gros sur un un
seul
je moi je fais d'accord puis oui en 2015
on devrait avec un cabinet qui est
paritaire
ce pardon et à la diversité aussi à la
diversité ou s'il joue l'atout sur les
deux aspects la diversité sanusi tessin
favori manuel ce matin légère mais je
veux je vois te regarde votre une chose
il ya beaucoup d'hommes blancs de
l'ontario qui sont pas dans le cabinet
qui se voyaient comme des vedettes et
qui vont et un député intelligent qui
sait qu'il ne sera pas ministre c'est un
problème pour un premier ministre
le bac bencher point intéressant puis a
pas de prix de consolation à donner
alors ce à un moment donné ça peut
devenir un problème pour le premier
ministre il faut falloir gérer les égos
et ça a l'air de salaire banal seul
d'époque c'est très important dans un
parlement et monsieur trudeau va devoir
faire ça mais en quelques secondes
là-dessus manuel ce n'est pas le prix à
payer pour avoir un petit cabinet mais
de toute façon monsieur monsieur trudeau
aurait géré des esgaulx soit y aurait à
gérer les égos des hommes blancs si des
femmes brillantes et rennes qui est
aussi sa serai vieux québec
ce problème d'un petit moi ce que je
remarque c'est que j'ai vraiment fait la
liste et sur la question de la parité de
la diversité dont je sais toujours est
ce que à la recherche de l'égalité on
sacrifie la compétence est vraiment
qu'on regarde le pedigree l'expérience
des femmes qui ont été nommés des gens
issus des communautés culturelles qui
ont été nommés on sent que monsieur
trudeau a presque réussi la quadrature
du cercle
la seule personne qui se retrouve dans
un ministère important on se dit cette
personne là et là principalement à cause
de ses états de service sa proximité
avec monsieur trudeau c'est navdeep
bains
le nouveau ministre de l'industrie entre
guillemets le mix appels mails en
innovation science et développement
économique pour quelqu'un dont
l'expérience professionnelle laisse
croire qu'ils étaient destinés à ça
c'est vraiment son appui à justin
trudeau depuis la toute première vue ses
qualités d'organisateur de choses quand
on a une qualité comme son cabinet il ya
aussi le fait qu'on a une qualité de
candidat à 20 et c'est tout un dommage
aux gens qui ont recruté les candidats
de l'équipe libérale de pouvoir avoir un
cabinet comme celui appuyé de l'essai du
jour montrent beaucoup de choses
avancent quand on se quitte le temps
fuit l'homme il ya deux choses que donc
je
vous entendre sur deux vous à l'eau le
poids du québec six ministres plus le
premier ministre mais s'il se finissent
au qu'un ministère économique important
à l'est qu'on l'à beaucoup souligné
aujourd'hui mais il ya les transports
les affaires extérieures etc
ouais en fait et je vous dirais qu'il ya
pas de vice premier ministre dans ce
cabinet là mais si on en avait un en
identifie puis je vais avec toute
réserve mais stéphane dion est pas très
loin je pense de ce titre-là endroit où
j'ai juste eu donc sûr d'avoir les
comités sur lesquels ils siègent
stéphane dion se dit que les ministres
des affaires étrangères mais il est le
président du comité sur les changements
climatiques l'énergie l'environnement
donc il vaut et polissage une ministre
catherine mécanos qui s'envoient paris
et les sur le comité du renseignement
comité de la sécurité publique et de la
sécurité nationale il est sûr beaucoup
beaucoup de comités stéphane guillon
dont qui va être un pilier du
gouvernement trudeau
même si vous êtes aux affaires
étrangères il voit les deux mains dans
la cousine du gouvernement quand même
parce qu'ils siègent sur des comités
très important donc c'est vrai qu'en
ministères économiques mais apporte
peut-être transport avec marc garneau on
est moins bien pourvus au québec mais
stéphane dion joue un rôle important
voilà marie je suis d'accord
j'arrive du clos quand même responsable
la famille des enfants il se trouve
qu'elle veuille forme ouidah québec
toute cette réforme des allocations pour
la garde d'enfants donc je pense qu'il
pourrait quand même avoir un profil
important mais pour revenir sur ce que
dit alec tout à l'heure sur la parité je
trouve qu'au québec pour pour cette
fois-ci d'accord avec alec au québec la
parité est plus ou moins équitable parce
que on a patrie moines madame joly
peut-être des comités du cabinet mais ça
veut pas dire que l est très présente en
chambre ou dans les nouvelles
ensuite madame bebo à l'acdi on sait que
ça a été fusionnée avec la femme d'un
chargeur pour un bureau à sherbrooke et
madame lebouthillier de deux gains ce
midi qui est revenu national donc au
québec les femmes ont quand même il sera
moins important mais le six ministres
sur 30 respecte le vin quelques pour
cent de la population québécoise au sein
du canada donc à ce niveau là c'est
respecter et emmanuel et michel
rapidement là dessus on entendu bon à
québec des sons de cloches plutôt
positif même la pierre karl péladeau qui
a dit ben il faut boire là
ce qui va se lier indulgent ce qui va
marquer patrice et on a décidé d'abolir
le job de leader du tenant du québec aux
deux leaders du québec qui a toujours
existé même se donne monsieur trudeau
peine et tout et c'est peut-être ça qui
vont manquer le plus parce qu'à loin si
vous avez un projet que vous voulez a
mené au gouvernement fédéral n'avait pas
l'intention du premier ministre du
premier coup c'est sur cette personne là
était un canal important et je pense que
même si elles n'existent pas
formellement
ça va venir par exister de façon réelle
sert probablement être monsieur garneau
puis moi je cherche pas tout à fait
d'accord avec mes collègues et les
transports c'est un ministère économique
si un ici en place aucun pays au monde
où ils transportent des ministères
économiques ce mandat oui et puis vous
avez raison mais est-ce qu'on a retiré
les infrastructures un peu de là bons
achats sont la vie est longue on va
reparler tout ça mais voyez ces images
là aujourd'hui cérémonie qu'on n'avait
jamais vu comme ça ottawa décide on a
fait le pari là dedans mettre plein la
vue d'inviter les écoliers les gens les
enfants et cetera un mot là-dessus
chacun pari réussi mais en même temps
j'imagine
on monte les attentes là on y voit
chacun alec excellente excellent travail
d'image aujourd'hui des relations
publiques on sait que le gouvernement
trudeau dans son entourage sont autour
de justin trudeau autres des gens qui
travaillent avec les médias sociaux qui
savent comment ça fonctionne donc justin
trudeau est pas le seul jeune dans son
entourage on sait comment ça fonctionne
tout était bien calibré peu seul petit
bémol peut-être beaucoup de français
dans la conférence de presse de justin
trudeau faudra juste et sa maman donné
peut-être les questions en anglais
après vingt minutes on pourrait donner
la parole à quelques journalistes
francophones mais à force je voudrais
que tu une journée c'est bien réussi sur
le plan de l'image
marie on se croyait on se croyait
quelquefois parfois aux états unis là
dans le genre de série
oui il ya des gens qu'ils étaient dans
le public mais ce que je remarque c'est
que cette rue est très chanceux
souvent les astres semblent s'aligner
avec lui il faut dire qu'à tarifs 11 et
15 degrés gros soleil donc y avait comme
2000 personnes à rideau hall moi j'ai
jamais vu 106 ans donc ça peut être aidé
l'oci qui fasse beau mais les gens et
avec un brin excité d'être là une mère
qui a dit qu'elle avait sorti son fils
de l'école parce que c'était un moment
historique puis elle voulait le vivre
donc il ya toute cette attente je vous
dis de changement et qui va devoir être
au rendez vous emmanuel un mot mais je
voudrais que justin trudeau a fait le
pari son pari politique au canadien
depuis le début c'est de dire aux
canadiens je vais vous embarquer dans
mon projet à la tête de ce pays là et
donc d'ouvrir les portes d'accueillir
les gens oui plus qu'une question cette
fleur bleue je trouve que plus que
quelque chose de relations publiques là
dedans il ya un message qui quand même
qui est important le test de ce c est ce
que le gouvernement trudeau sera capable
de maintenir cette ouverture cette
proximité qui rafraîchissante qui semble
plaire aux canadiens c'est ce qu'il
faudra voir à l'usure et michel faut
dire qu'on est passé est d'une certaine
façon d'un extrême à l'autre là oui on a
pas du tout de même genre du cabinet en
termes d'âge en termes de composition
entrouverte termes d'ouverture en termes
de priorités show un bémol l éclat dit
la conférence de presse qu une seule
question en français je comprends qu'on
voulait faire la différence à l'estivé
d'entre eux qui avaient une liste épi
qui craint qui gérait ses conférences de
presse mais il faut faire attention à ça
ce trudeau et pour lui c'est tellement
naturel être bilingue pense que tout le
monde l'est tout lé temps c'est pas tout
à fait simplement donné ils pourraient
avoir un problème d'image avec les
francophones s'y fait pas attention
voilà je crois qu'on a et c'est un tour
de force réussi à faire le tour quand
même des des éléments importants
souligné merci à vous quatre en reparler
bien sûr on a annoncé tout à l'heure
discours du trône 1 messieurs dames qui
travaillait à tahoua discours du trône
le 4 décembre
donc c'est les choses s'emballent 3
décembre tour du parlement des 338
députés à la chambre des communes alors
les les appels aux dons et de il y aura
des gestes qui devrait apaiser ses
grandes attentes
merci infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir voire avant